there's no time
[Music]
13 o clock hey you guys it's Tuesday
again and it's time for episode 126 now
this was just requested like a couple of
weeks ago and I didn't even have it on
my list for whatever reason and then
like somebody said hey why don't you do
a show about the Son of Sam I see you
did one on the zodiac and I was like Oh
duh why don't we do what some say yeah
because I don't even know why I didn't
think of it because I have like millions
of other serial killers on the West but
for some reason not this one
when we started this show we wanted to
do stuff that was kind of off the beaten
path true that was really how you
competed when you were a new channel is
to do things that other people weren't
doing yeah now that we're more
established we can go back and do real
common cases like Son of Sam everyone
really should know about this case yeah
it really it's like a very very common
case and there's a [ __ ] ton of like
documentaries about it there were like
movies about it songs about it all kinds
well it could be that I'm taking it for
granted you know also because of our age
there's a lot of younger people that may
not know who the hell Sam is yeah
because this I mean other countries I'm
not from New York City but I mean in New
York City this was like a big deal like
in the late 70s and you know the whole
city was like you know terrorized and
even showed up in Cypress Hill lyrics
yes I presume yeah there's been a lot of
man song yeah even though I should say
according to Wikipedia the song psycho
killer by the Talking Heads which
everybody thought was about David
Berkowitz apparently it's not about
David Berkowitz but there were a bunch
of other ones that were about yeah now
there's also we kind of want to cover
too because I feel like there's kind of
a big controversy about whether David
Berkowitz acted alone
or whether he was part of some extended
cult like he wasn't because there was
like a lot of [ __ ] about some people
that were witnesses to some of the
crimes and they saw different people and
you know different
her hair and like different builds and
stuff like that so and then later on
like he kind of said some [ __ ] about
yeah I'm gonna call it it was a whole
bunch of us and I only did three of them
and blah blah blah and all this other
kind of stuff so we'll sort of get into
that a little bit later yeah it's not a
real complicated case we're just gonna
do that overview probably last about an
hour the show
well yeah I like I said I'm not putting
limits on [ __ ] tomorrow if it ends up
being an hour fine if it ends up being
two hours fine it's like I know I know
that a lot of people have contacted me
and say they like the longer format we
didn't really intend for them to go
longer we just kind of said you know
[ __ ] it we're just gonna not worry about
how long it is so sometimes we don't pay
attention so sometimes they go two hours
two hours 20 minutes and we're like holy
crap we didn't really want it on that
long especially like when we go off on
tangents and whatnot so you know like I
said some of them might be longer some
of them might be shorter we're not like
okay it's on you then you can do long as
you want to do yeah I'm not here for rod
I would think it would piss some
probably and take that long but actually
just be talking about it actually just
lengthen the show did it that's what I
mean yeah I'm not firing on all
cylinders yet I just started drinking
well you we just woke up this thing woke
up this morning with it just like a bad
headache cat woke up three o'clock in
the morning she'll do that didn't feel
right all day running around on me
jumping on my chest yeah she does that's
me pretty much every morning yeah she
did you get old
yeah well cuz I'm used to him yeah I'm
used to it she does that every morning
right around four am she decides oh and
look she just came in there but yeah
writer been around for I am seriously
between 4:00 and 5:00 a.m. she will come
in and go hey mommy hey mommy and she'll
start like needing like on my shoulder
like I've taken to sleeping with a
pillow there just so she doesn't claw me
you know what I mean so cuz she loves to
just need at this one particular spot
and then she'll go like climb up on my
chest and like lay there and pull her
and [ __ ] like that stick her little
whiskers and movies it's just funny um
audiobooks selling selling like crazy
I'm coming yeah part 2 is actually a
retro actively selling part one which I
got the the sound proofing done for the
sound proofing bits in the closet right
there behind you turned my closet
now a soundproof now sound booth has
shelf has all the foam all around to
make some little false walls in the back
so she's got a little phone booth sighs
think she could stand there put a shelf
in there so she could put her laptop and
the microphones so it should turn out
real well we're gonna get we're gonna
calibrate the the microphone and see
what kind of background signature we can
get in there I can't I can even I could
probably even insulate it even more if I
have to yeah we got extra foam but this
will allow us to record a lot better
than the actually part to was to pretty
good standards I think this will be yeah
that or better because I had kind of a
quasi soundproof yeah we have like
blankets and quilts and yeah like stuff
on the inside and everything so that one
came out sounded pretty good yeah but I
want to redo weird redo part one volume
one you know with the new center I'm
gonna do unseen hand and then I want to
do some of my fiction and the fiction
come then we'll go back and touch up to
Steve Mara books and then we'll probably
do mammoth mountain because I mean I'm
gonna come up with us with it with an
updated mammoth mountain with some newer
stuff yeah we're gonna add more stuff
because it was yeah it was kind of a
short but one horribly short or
something like that but you know we
wanted to add more to it because it was
kind of more to it and that's more stuff
and we remember a smaller operation back
then was my first one so we could
actually pull on fiction we could
actually do a lot better job on a second
edition of that yeah do you guys are
gonna like it that's what yeah so like I
said it over the next year the next
upcoming month together like redo a lot
of the audio books I'm gonna put a bunch
of my fiction on audiobook which it's
never been before
I might like do a second edition where I
like you know with change out the covers
like modernize the covers and whatnot
and then I got to do faceless villain
volume three which I'm hoping you'll be
out by fall of 2019 that's what I'm
shooting for
we'll see how that goes like I said I've
got it all outlined and everything
everybody's just you know they really
want part three to come out of faceless
villain we can get it out but we've got
to go back and touch up the old catalog
yes it's just complaints on the audience
it's just not a lot but some of the
audio is yeah it's passable but it's not
it's not great it could be a lot better
because I didn't really have anything to
and as Jenny's making these new
customers because part 2 is out it's now
serious series so people are buying part
1 and part 2 because we're making these
new customers we we got a touch up the
[ __ ] that we did in the past yeah cuz I
want them all to be that way we don't
want to lose customers basically yeah I
want them all to be like the same yeah
the same standard that's what I'm trying
to you and I'm trying to like you know
do everything with my back catalogue and
get all that so before I do any I would
think we can get out of second edition
part 1 within a couple months and then
maybe a second edition second edition
face on the scene hand that's probably
about four months from now maybe yeah
right we'll see and then and then we'll
get the you know we'll see maybe even
less yeah then we're gonna do the bring
a whole bunch of fiction to market that
you guys are gonna like in a one-stop
shop probably two collections yeah
probably yeah and that way you can
because and it's never that hasn't been
available no I've never done audiobook
versions of that yeah of the fiction and
a lot of the fictions have been out for
a really long time been out a long time
and it's cool it's cool I've read yeah
it's pretty it's kind of like Clive
Barker is kinda yeah it's just you know
nonfiction is an easier sell and I like
you know writing true crime I like
writing paranormal [ __ ] yeah you know so
it just seemed like an easy roll like a
lot of people if they don't know who you
are they're not gonna buy your fiction
because they don't know if it sucks or
not right no I'm the same yeah
nonfiction is just sells a lot better
nothing that we've experienced is how
much better
true crime cells versus paranormal and
there's a lot more much wider audience
and wider audience and there's a lot
more true crime like fans out there and
a lot more cases that that are out there
when you're dealing with paranormal you
have to weed through the hokey [ __ ] to
find the cases that are kind of good
yeah and there's a limited amount of
those I always kind of wanted to do a
UFO book but there's just so much of
that now you know well
and the thing is a lot of paranormal
books are not good yeah well shitty so
you could be put out a good one and
people don't buy because of all the rest
of them well it's better to yeah cuz you
like guilt by association but you know
that's why I wanted to do kind of like a
serious one because there's really not a
lot like that yeah but yeah so that'll
be coming up also um if you are one of
our patrons on patreon then you saw the
post that I made earlier today actually
wasn't today it's when we're recording
this it was a couple days ago um I got a
message from one of our patrons that was
like you know you guys don't really post
anything on patreon and you know maybe
you should and stuff and I was like yeah
maybe we should it's like I always meant
to like post more stuff on patreon
leaking it like outtake videos or like
you know just silly [ __ ] like that and I
just somehow never get around to it um
finally the part where this operation
where we almost need a damn secretary
she needs help
she's gotten so much stuff that she has
to do really and it's stuff that I
really can't help her with I'm not
really good at that kind of stuff you
know while I was waiting for him to come
in here and record the show I redesigned
my entire web site graphic designer
sorry I can't do it you know but I can
just not do anything it's almost getting
to the point where we're gonna have to
hire somebody although honestly I was
thinking about the other day I said even
if I had the money to hire somebody
which I don't but even if I did I'd
probably like up their ass all the time
like what are you doing you're not doing
that right yeah I'm one of those like
control freaky kinda part of it part of
it is that were new yeah and so we have
to worry about back-catalogue
too you know I mean we're picking that
up if that was done right you could just
move forward you wouldn't have to move
backwards to clean up to technological
issues we had it with it with the with
the old problem but I don't mind it you
know once it's out of the way now that I
know what I'm doing right yeah cuz I
have to honestly it's like I'm one of
those kind of people I don't like other
people telling me what to do I don't
like having to learn things from other
people it's like if I have to know how
to do something then I will learn to do
it right myself because I don't want to
like I don't I don't trust anyone else
yeah
technology you know we can begin
self-contained to unit yeah may take us
time to get it right but eventually we
will work that's the kind of people we
are ok we'll probably just let it roll
but you know I have a background in
sales I know that if you want to sell
you want to make money you have to have
a good product if not you won't have any
brand loyalty you know how good you know
I'll have any customer loyalty so I mean
and honestly when I first started doing
all this kind of [ __ ] I didn't know
anything about audio editing I didn't
know anything about video editing I did
teach myself all that learned it all as
we went I just kind of like figured it
out or how to or how to self publish a
book yeah how to target market books
things like that you know I'm like
constantly stressed out but like I said
I don't think I could farm it out to
another person because I don't trust
another person to do it to do it
correctly and do it on the timeline that
I want it done on I'm used to juggling a
bunch of different stuff at once she's
not really used to that I am I just
don't like it she puts herself under all
the stress my chill out man this stuff
it's coming yeah she does great yes is
my personality well I like I like the
feeling of having everything done and
everything being ahead of time you know
what we're doing now is I don't like
last-minute [ __ ] I don't like it what
we're doing now that's gonna take months
so yeah I know it just get used to it I
have this look like look at this you
guys this is my list this is just this
is for this week this is my list for
things to do this week yeah and I cross
them off with little colored markers
when they get finished but yeah that's
just what my personality type is like
yeah but yeah speaking of that like I
said so you know in view of the patreon
thing I really want to try and post more
stuff on patreon I want to like do more
like little couple minute videos like
maybe like I said like outtake videos or
you know kitten work extra kitty videos
because we've started taking more videos
of the kitty because you guys seem to
like those Kitty videos that I've been
putting in the commercial break and I
got one letter yesterday yeah you did
yeah so we wanted to start doing that I
also want to maybe do because you know
how for the $20 plus patrons I've been
doing like a quarterly mail out we're
like I'm
free books or t-shirts or whatever I
want like people on the lower tiers to
also kind of maybe get in on that action
so I think what I might do is quarterly
I might do like a drawing so I'm gonna
do like a random drawing from one of the
other patrons and they'll get the same
thing I also want to start maybe doing
early access because like I said and I
think I mentioned in this in the patreon
post that Tom and I are trying to we're
gonna all the shows are gonna come out
the same days you know Tuesday Friday
Sunday but we're trying to up our
production schedule we're trying to
record like two shows it wants three
shows at once instead of leaving
everything until like the day before
it's supposed to go jams up the schedule
too much we got it we got to do it like
professional outfits do it where you sit
down for like three days and just knock
out two months worth and yeah so it's
like in some ways I don't like because
we can't keep it's topical but I was
gonna be delayed but it'll be much
easier for me so what we're doing is
we're just gonna start like for the
podcast episodes because we're longer
we're probably just gonna do two at once
so it'll be the like the next two weeks
and then movie reviews I've already got
like the next three or four in the can
so you know so if so if you requested
something and it seems like it's taking
forever yes probably why because right
yeah and like I said I'm sure it's not
gonna be as interactive yeah would be in
the comments section but yeah I mean
we're still gonna check the comments
everything like that but just for the
you know in the interest of my sanity
and for me not having a nervous
breakdown we're we're gonna try and
really like record more stuff while
we're sitting in here oh and I've been
getting friend requests on Facebook I've
been accepting some of them if you get
accepted and you don't hear from me
don't be offended man I've got thousands
of people on my facebook I can't talk to
everybody
I'm almost to my limit I try to like
answer everybody but like it's I can't
and you know we're busy not only with
this stuff but other stuff that we have
Google and sometimes and I used to check
Facebook every day and now it's like
every three or four days obviously
that's like I hate to say it but you
know I I feel bad too it's like you know
friends that live around here and it's
like I feel like I haven't talked to
them like they're like are you mad at me
or some our new record
schedule actually free up a lot of her
time to finish these audio books you
know to clean up yeah and the new stuff
that's coming yeah yeah so like I said
since we're gonna be doing some shows
ahead of time then that means I can post
them early on patreon or I can at least
like tell the patrons like what topics
are coming up or what movies are coming
up or whatever so you know I'm still
kind of like working out the details but
that's probably what we're gonna do this
year so hopefully that will all go well
the only other thing I was gonna
announce was our last movie review which
was Halloween 3 season of the witch
we've got a really good response on that
seems like a lot of people are super
into that maybe it wasn't just us but
yeah so go check that out if you haven't
already and now after all of that yeah
I've got that out of way let's start
talking about Sun yeah now yeah well
here was something I didn't know until I
started kind of looking into this but
like David Berkowitz that was not the
name he was born with cuz he was
actually adopted okay um his mom here's
what happened his mom was married to
this guy named Tony Falco and she they
were only married for a couple of years
and then he took off for some other
woman so the mom whose name was Betty
Broder then she started an affair with a
married guy and got pregnant presumably
with the person who would end up being
David Berkowitz okay now no one is quite
sure why she gave the baby up for
adoption
speculation is because this married guy
was like yeah you can't have a baby and
give it my last name so you just give it
to somebody else so she gave him up and
he was adopted by the Berkowitz family
who rent they ran like a hardware store
so I must've been back in the 50s yeah
yeah Berkowitz was born in 1953 yes
another another era yeah so he was
actually so he was actually born Richard
David Falco that was the name that he
had
actually kind of a cool name yeah but
then when he was adopted and the
Berkowitz couple gave him you know their
name
so David Berkowitz is still alive still
in prison
serving several consecutive life
sentences he's actually come up for
parole a couple of times but he has
stated he does not want parole and a lot
of times he does not show up for the
hearings because he doesn't think he
deserves to be let out which you know I
think we can all agree with him on that
they would never let him out yeah I
don't think they would let him out
anyway even if even if he did want to be
but um I mean here's the thing I would
he do he's unqualified to do anything
yeah and honestly I think early this
early in 2018
he actually had a heart attack and he
needed heart surgery but he has
apparently recovered I haven't heard
that he's died or anything like that so
but that was like a year ago that that
happened so um he is formally credited
with six murders and seven attempted
murders of seven people that he shot and
that didn't die so here's the thing so
let's talk a little bit about like I
said he was adopted
um it's interesting how they didn't
really notice anything super peculiar
about him as a kid he was kind of
troubled kind of a bully
he kind of like got in trouble for like
petty [ __ ] um but nothing that got the
law involved you know what I mean like
now it was bad enough that his parents
did contact like a psychotherapist and
go like what's the matter with him well
hey baby I can't welcome you stick her
little face it please just don't walk
across my little buttons okay but yeah
so so it was nothing terrible but it was
enough that they thought something was
the matter with him you know what I mean
so you know there's that whole thing and
then when he was 17 he actually joined
the army and I believe he was infantry
and served in the US and in South Korea
okay and he was
for you know his for years or whatever
now after he got out he actually looked
for his birth mother and found her and
then the birth mother told him about him
being illegitimate which was a big deal
in the 50s you know what I mean and
apparently this was really like kind of
a formative moment for him because it
felt like he always said that he felt
like he didn't like he didn't really
have an identity or you know what I mean
he just felt like he was apart from
everyone for some reason it kind of
sounds like old what's-his-name the guy
that does another really big serial
killer who was illegitimate thought his
mom was his sister he's only the
greatest one the great the greatest one
what was that guy's name Bondi yeah yeah
but yeah this was a this was a similar
kind of thing so you know from all the
psychotherapist that have kind of looked
into it and stuff like that said this
was kind of a big deal like him finding
out about the circumstances of his birth
and you know him being like they called
it like the primary crisis like of his
life like he felt like you need to
belong anywhere yeah like Ted Bundy was
and all yeah that type of thing so he
always felt like he was like apart from
everyone which was funny cuz I that was
something from that era there's a lot of
guys that are born today from single
mothers you know with you know kind of
unknown backgrounds and they don't end
up like this it wasn't as stigmatized
well like I said and we've talked about
this on some of our other serial killer
shows I feel like the less stigma there
is about that kind of [ __ ] I think the
better off we all are yeah because
doesn't affect the kids right you make a
big deal about oh your illegitimate you
make a big deal about the kid being gay
you make a big deal about something like
you make a big deal about it and you
give the kid a [ __ ] compliment
complex then they start acting in weird
and then it messes them up like it warps
people's brains and look how that [ __ ]
happen I mean I'm not saying like if you
you know got older if he because he was
in his early 20s when he found out
I mean I don't know if he knew he was
adopted I think he did but I don't think
he knew about the whole Oh my mom was
having an affair with a married guy and
like you know that's why she gave me up
but you know yeah that would be
traumatic to find out particularly when
you were in your 20s but I feel like
nowadays it wouldn't be as traumatic
like so traumatic they would turn back
then you know the society was very
conformist it was really cookie cutter
ooh yeah it was like this and if it
wasn't like this it was wrong so I think
that's what that's what affected him
that way yeah I mean because they they
weren't like everybody else so I so he
kind of stayed in contact with his birth
mother and his half-sister for a while
but then you know that communication
kind of broke down um after he got out
of the army he just kind of worked you
know Johnny live work for the Postal
Service you know he was like a letter
sorter and [ __ ] like that
so in the mid-nineteen seventies about
1976 is when he started committing
crimes now it is thought and they didn't
know this until later on but it is
thought that David Berkowitz committed
at least 1,400 arsons around the New
York City area and Lou said they didn't
find that out until much later on I did
it yeah so he started like starting
starting fires and [ __ ] like that
because that's a big serial kids serial
killing anniversary maniac serial
killing and arson are very closely
correlated for whatever reason and that
definitely seems to be the case here
that's weird I've read about so most
power maniacs and they're just they're
thinking and just the way they see
things are totally different from us
like they're walking around and we me
and you would just be walking around
just seeing the normal environment what
they're noticing is what they can set on
fire like if I just take my lighter at
night hit the edge of that fence with
all that Ivy girl into that chain-link
fence
it'll burn this entire fence down and
that house you know they can see where
the fire is gonna go they know how fire
behaves with you it would never occur to
me and you know but they're just had
this huge over huge like temptation to
start that fire cuz they can see it yeah
yeah I mean they see the potential for
the fire well because they're driven to
I've gotta set that on fire I think
that's part of
what fascinates me about serial killers
is that particularly when you interview
them or like when you read stuff that
they wrote and I'm just like the the way
they think is just like so alien yeah
you know what I mean it's like why would
the [ __ ] would that even occur to you
yeah I'm glad it does it because that
means I'm not psychic I'm not driving
around and then see something go boy
that would rear that sure would burn boy
that would burn boy I could cut that guy
in half if I were to set that on fire
that would burn the whole block down you
know I mean yeah you don't think that
way that's bizarre yeah but yeah so um
yeah so there were all the arsons
apparently he started doing that kind of
stuff that petty larceny that kind of
stuff again petty larceny and arson very
closely correlated with later serial
killing as it was in this case
now I didn't actually know this either
because David Berkowitz before they
caught him and before he was called Son
of Sam he was actually called the 44
caliber killer because that was the 44
caliber like Bulldog in most of his
crimes however the first crime that he
admitted that he later admitted to was
actually a stabbing and this happened he
had a hunting knife and he stabbed these
two girls it was on Christmas Eve of
1975 now one of the victims was never
identified so I guess she just took off
however the other victim was named
Michelle Forman now neither of these
women died Michelle Foreman did have to
be hospitalized which is why they know
who she is but they don't know who the
other person was so evidently it was
very minor so this was David Berkowitz
his first botched murder attempt and it
was with a hunting knife now from this
point forward subsequently he always
used the same revolver yeah so now the
first shooting that is attributed to him
this happened on July 29th 1976 and this
was in the Bronx in the Pelham Bay Area
about 1:10 in the morning
this was Donna Lauria who was 18 years
old and her friend Jody Valenti who was
19 years old they had just come from a
nightclub called peach trees and they
were
sitting in Jodie's Oldsmobile just
talking and you know talking about their
night or whatever so Donna gets out of
the car presumably to go into her house
or you know walk down the street or what
have you this man starts walking quickly
toward her this startled her as it would
and she started to say something like
what is this like her who are you or
whatever then he pulled the gun out of a
paper bag
that he had been holding and he shot her
so she was killed instantly he also
killed no he also shot Jodi Valenti
although it only hit her in the thigh
and then he shot again but it missed and
then he took off so Jodi Valenti lived
now she said and like I said every
witness description of this dude is
slightly different and I think that's
kind of like fueling the speculation
that maybe he wasn't working alone
I mean I kind of feel like he was but I
can see why you would think otherwise
you know I mean so Jodi Valenti she
lived she said that he was a white male
in his 30s that he had a pale complexion
about 5 foot 9
she said he weighed about a hundred
sixty pounds short dark curly hair in a
quote unquote mod style 160 pounds at
five nine I mean he was pretty thin yeah
see this is why that's a little strange
because he's kind of a short dumpy guy
from yeah he's yeah he's kind of yeah I
wouldn't call him fat but he's dumped
each other you know kind of how I
remember him I'm Addison yeah I don't
know how tall he is you know in real
life but you know what I mean he
probably was probably about five foot
nine I guess five eight five foot nine
that's about average and at five foot
eight yeah I think it depends I think
the national average of the u.s. is
going down yeah yeah now this is
interesting because this description of
this person
Donna Lauria's father also saw
presumably who the person who is the
shooter and he described him the same
way and he also said that there had been
this yellow compact car
and it was like cruising up and down
like in the area like it was like they
were looking for somebody so he said
that he's seen that guy get out of that
car and it was the same description at
that Jody Valenti it seen okay like I
said this was in the Bronx and this was
the first murder attributed to him and
let me talk about this pistol
alright this pistol actually is a
legendary pistol in the United States
when I was a kid back in the 80s the
Charter Arms bulldog was kind of a kava
Stila a good carry option in other words
it was a small it was something that you
it could actually still buy it was
inexpensive it was a small frame I
believe five shot forty for Special
revolver and 40 for special in those
days was pretty pretty attractive
because it had power similar to a 45 but
it was a rimmed cartridge that you could
use in a revolver this is going on in
the days you know I remembered from the
days where the the beretta 92f and all
these new wonderful 9 millimeters were
coming out and they were big and fat
they carried 17 18 rounds of
9-millimeter and there weren't any good
hollow points for it so thought people
were skeptical of 9 millimeters but they
they they liked that old trusty 45 like
the 1911 but you couldn't conceal it but
the Charter Arms bulldog you concealed
it was small enough for that they give
you five shots or something kind of like
a 45 now it was normally in in 44
special in these days and that that car
that calibers conduct obsolete now I
don't think you'll be able to find much
of it but it was just a lead
hollow-point I don't even think it had a
jacket on it was just LED or LED
round-nose and tell you what one shot of
that and the right spot would mess you
up and that's you know why he's using it
yeah wasn't a weak pistol by any means
yeah this is a large caliber I mean yeah
the fact that so many of his victims
survived is actually kind of amazing
yeah um you know I think it was me I
don't know if there's a hard hitting
pistol yeah
funny thing is is that it was kind of
low-cost they didn't really wear too
well if you shot him a lot they started
to get loose and they'd lose timing in
the cylinder but most people mostly
carried them more than they shot them
yeah you can still find them every now
and then but they're nothing compared to
say like a Smith & Wesson they're kind
of cheap Charter Arms is not really a
high-class
company and that and and the Bulldog was
really their best seller that was you
know I feel like there's probably serial
killer groupies out there that want to
collect all the weapons like the types
of weapons that all the famous serial
killers had yeah I mean I haven't seen
one in a long time a Charter Arms
bulldog he also made him 38 babies don't
make them I don't even try not probably
not I'd have to check but I haven't seen
one maybe the whole is with no no this
sales went up well yeah that actually
made it famous you know because I have
to say that the apartment building that
this [ __ ] lived and they changed
the address because he lived there they
changed the number you know obviously
the street name was Charter Arms Bulldog
was known about in the gun circles a lot
of cops used it as a backup revolver
that you know and like an ankle holster
yeah yeah alright so then there was
another shooting now this one neither of
the victims died this actually took
place October 23rd 1976 in Queens so
he's moved to a different borough now
the victims were Karl De Niro who was 20
years old and rosemary Keenan who was 18
years old just like the first two
victims these who were both sitting in a
car they had been out for a night out
and they were you know sitting there car
talking or whatever and then suddenly
all the windows like exploded like the
windows exploded they actually panicked
and started driving away they did not
realize that someone was shooting at
them at first even though Karl De Niro
actually had been shot in the head so
and was bleeding profusely from a head
wound as head wounds usually do and
actually drove now rosemary was not all
that wounded
I don't think she was hit by a bullet
she was cut up by the glass but she was
pretty much fine
Karl De Niro actually lived but he
needed a metal plate in his skull from
the head wound but [ __ ] and his lucky to
a bit of live that is hardcore yeah I
just he didn't realize that he'd been
shot I'd like to see what happened he
might have been hit with lead round nose
you know and the head is round and hard
and if it doesn't directly impact it
won't pop a hole through the skull if
it's a glancing blow the skull could
actually deflect a red LED round nose
bullet because it the point is that the
point of the bullet is round you know
what I mean so the bullet can't get a
bite into the bone yeah you know it's
why flat points flat pointed bullets
actually kind of work a little better
and also hollow points on round objects
like skulls but he's lucky to have
survived that's what I thought it would
still be like getting hit in the head
with a hammer a glancing blow of a
hammer you'd be able to like drive off
after I mean when I understand the
adrenaline and like you'd be paying like
what the [ __ ] has happened and you know
when you get injured really badly like
I've had it happened to you it's like
you don't if you don't see it like you
don't realize you know what I mean and
you just kind of like just start running
or whatever it is you do and he just
started driving and didn't realize that
somebody had shot him in the [ __ ]
head
44 specials a heavy bullet I think it
was 200 grains of lead I mean yes that's
about almost what a almost what a 45
bullet weighs get hit in the head with
that yeah be pretty traumatic even a
glancing blow be like getting hit a
glancing blow of a hammer yeah so the
cops did find some 44 caliber bullets
like embedded in the car but they were
all like deformed and [ __ ] up and they
said okay well though some of them were
[ __ ] up they're like we're never gonna
be able to figure out like what gun that
came from now interestingly because this
had happened in Queens and the first
shooting happened in the Bronx they did
not associate the two crimes because
they just thought it was two random
shootings I mean it's New York City in
the 70s it was a lot of crime and you
know it was different police precincts
also so they didn't really see any
reason why these two crimes would be
related so we're all [ __ ] up because
it was an all but all led bullet without
a cop
jacket around it just like I told you
yeah I didn't survive impact it just
mashes up especially the little soft you
know yeah so there's just you know and
ends up look like a chewed up piece of
bubblegum it looks like that's probably
yeah but they said yeah there's no way
we could figure out what firearm that
came from in particular so the next one
took place on November 27th 1976 this
was two girls Donna DiMasi who was 16
years old and Joanne lemmino who was 18
years old they were walking home late at
night from a movie this was also in
Queens but a different neighborhood and
they were they had come home and they
were actually standing on the porch of
Joanne's house it's like talking and
this guy in military fatigues starts
approaching them as though and starts
asking them for directions and then
pulls out the revolver and shoots them
now after they fell to the ground he
fired a bunch more he also hit the
building and a bunch of other stuff and
then ran away now a neighbor actually
heard the gunshots and came out to help
he saw a blond man with a pistol in his
hand whether this was the shooter I mean
we're assuming it is but I don't know I
feel like Berkowitz maybe later maybe
wore a wig because I feel like some of
the witnesses later said they thought
the hair looked faker looked like a wig
so that might have been the case in this
instance but the neighbor definitely
said I saw a blond man running away from
the apartment building with a gun in his
hand now Donna Demasi her she had a
wound in her neck but it was not
life-threatening so she actually
survived Joanne lemmino was shot in the
back she also survived but she is a
paraplegic so neither of those victims
died but they didn't have a fun it's
just a weird situation you get a guy who
actually completes four years of service
in the in the military some of it in
Korea you know I served in Korea yet he
didn't mature to a point to where you're
like I'm gonna go around shooting girls
what is it that makes a man go you know
what I'm gonna dress up in my army
uniform I'm gonna shoot the prettiest
girls I see what kind of [ __ ]
[ __ ] is that that's what kind see that's
what kills me like I said this is what
fascinates me about serial killers
because you have to make a conscious
decision yeah to wake up one morning and
so today I'm gonna start being a serial
killer yeah I mean I can weird is that I
mean to me it's more conceivable that
you'd have like a 16 or a 17 year old
insel living in his mom's basement that
never doesn't even know any women you
know I mean never dated anyway because
teenagers are like this but this is a
guy who went through four years of
military service in Korea which should
have brought him into close contact with
lots of he had a job yeah yes I mean
what kind of issues normal what kind of
issues can't you work out by that time
evidently some big ones in this case yes
I'm just saying I mean I just I just
can't I just can't imagine that you know
what [ __ ] them girls I'm gonna kill him
cuz she does that yeah and it's weird
because he didn't seem to have you know
how like some of these recent like mass
shooters like wasn't it like elliot
rodger some of those other retards that
like you know that no women will have
sex with me therefore all women are evil
there's no kill them but it's like this
guy I mean David Berkowitz never really
said anything like that yeah I mean if
he was a guy like that though he should
have grown out of that by this time you
would think you would think I think
there are guys that are watching the
detriment of society I think there are
guys that are like that but I don't
think they're like that for very long no
I mean I think they grow out of it
within maybe months sometimes yeah I
mean depending on their situation you
would think I mean and I know this is
like me you know dudes don't mature as
fast as girls they just don't that's not
in the same way and not in the same way
but I do feel like once a dude is 30 he
should like not be doing that [ __ ]
anymore
oh no we talking about you shouldn't be
even be thinking that [ __ ] by the time
he's 16 well this in an ideal world
these kind of problems really should be
worked out
by ten eleven you would think a lot of
the [ __ ] that serial killers do is
juvenile yeah yeah it's kind of like
Cody yeah they're like stunted it's like
stunted growth of something that in the
infant might do you know I mean but this
and they're trying particularly these
types of serial killers that want like
the accolades like you know what I mean
cuz he like would you know leave letters
for the police and blah blah blah
and you know like zodiac and people like
that would do I feel like that's a very
like you said it's a very juvenile yeah
power play like you want to feel like a
badass because I mean these people feel
powerless obviously want power they have
all this anger and they want power yeah
and then they try to get it by murdering
the weakest of the people in cowardly
ways how does that make you powerful
that's what do you mean it's like
sneaking up just say yeah with the
zodiac it's like just sneaking up on
people that are just sitting in their
cars mind and they were in business yeah
you want to impress nothing badass about
that I wanted to powerfully want to
impress me go attack the police station
it's like dude yeah yeah do something's
gonna take balls see it out of me
I mean don't do that oh yeah you know go
20 for 20 versus one the hard way you
against these other armed guys yeah
don't just like it right up to a car and
like she's 16 your girl's gonna kill her
cuz she got a nice booty yeah I'm
talking about she got a nice booty I'm
have to kill that and like I said this
the same kind of [ __ ] this dude is doing
he's just walking up to like random
people walking down the street or random
people sitting in cars that are mostly
like teenagers are just in their 20s or
whatever you know hey we just went to a
movie and we're sitting in the car and
all of a sudden some [ __ ] comes
up and shoot you in the [ __ ] window
yeah [ __ ] man I'm trying to put myself
into his shoes and I just can't like
it's alien to me like why the [ __ ] like
look I get I get angry I like I've been
angry enough people it's like man if it
was legal to strangle you right now I
totally would but just like a random
person that's just like walking down the
street yeah of the opposite sex yeah why
why I don't understand it like I don't
feel like punching somebody unless they
do something that really really annoys
me
[Laughter]
you don't maybe if they're just doing
nothing i don't care i don't even see i
don't even pay attention okay so the
next shooting happened on January 30th
1977 this was Christine Freud she was 26
her fianc fiance was named John Diehl
and he was 30 again they were sitting in
their car near the Long Island Rail Road
station this was also in Queens they
were actually they went to they had gone
to see the movie Rocky and then they
were gonna go to a nightclub to go
dancin like you do after you go see a
movie and then here comes [ __ ] and
it's not him Sam and he comes up and
starts shooting into the car so John
drives away like panicking because he's
like [ __ ] somebody's shooting into my
car he didn't really sustain that many
injuries you know he was mostly okay but
Christine was actually shot two times
and died later at the hospital so at
this point the police are beginning to
link all these crimes together mostly
because they realized they've all been
committed with a 44 caliber pistol and
they realized that the mo is very
similar the cookies trying to move the
cam she's trying to move the camera she
thinks it's a bad angle maybe I don't
know try to move the camera what are you
doing cats trying to move the camera
leave it alone leave a camera losses
hilarious yeah I become the day to a cat
that's why you love it you call yourself
that all the time this cat is like she's
like a super genius like I know
everybody says that about their kids
yeah there are dogs and cats and stuff
but no seriously that's Brees Mara she's
she's trying to take the camera yeah she
wants to see she looks at us the top of
the left like you can't see it but she's
peeking at me over the top of the laptop
right now like so do you not like
yeah anyway yeah ridiculous she's the
camera woman now okay so at this stage
like I said police are starting to link
all the crimes together now at first
they think they're looking for multiple
suspects like I said because the first
couple shootings they have like a
dark-haired person that some people have
seen and then the other shootings blonde
haired person so they produce composite
sketches of two people thinking there
are multiple suspects
yes that's what a multiple suspect
theory came well yeah there was other
[ __ ] too I mean like I said I don't
think anybody is crazy or like oh you're
crazy conspiracy theorist for thinking
that I'm not saying that there was like
a satanic cult involved or anything like
that but it's not crazy to think that
because a lot of people did describe
different perpetrators different
vehicles even like in the same you know
area so it's not crazy to think that
maybe he wasn't working alone like maybe
he had you know an accomplice or two
accomplices you know I don't think it
was a satanic cult or anything like that
because most of that was largely
[ __ ] you know back in see our show
on the city yeah for further information
but I don't know I I don't know how I
fallen I'm not gonna take like a hard
stand either way because I can see how
you could think both things just about
half way more we probably are yeah we're
probably about the halfway point so
since Kitty will have to do some
Cambridge she left because she's like
trying to eat the camera yeah cameras on
a tripod it's got a little handled she
was grabbing the handle with her mouth
with her mouth and trap and then trying
to like polish she also kind of tried to
hit it with her hand first geez that's
why so that's why they can't that's why
this she's very observant whatever we do
she tries to do the same thing she tries
to turn the sink on with your hands
because she likes to drink out of this
scene yeah the bathroom sink I've caught
her trying to pull this the handles cuz
we have handles because she sees us a
little bit yeah try to pull him and
she's be in the sink because she likes
water to drip on her self honor she
thinks that's a shower
yeah I'm on the kid I know that loves
water she loves water I mean I've seen
other like YouTube videos with cats were
like a bath but it's very very unusual
she water come splash on her yeah she'll
get she'll curl
in the sink and be like and then you
have to like turn the drips on and then
she watches like they drip on her butt
and she'd be looking and then she's like
we're on her back when she like looks it
off and seriously I can't even do the
laundry with a second she hears the
dryer open yeah she's like my laundry
and she jumps into the dryer and she's
like messing around all the clothes
what's she doing can I help you would
throw the pile of laundry down she's a
short-haired cat she doesn't shed so
there's not much
yeah because otherwise because our other
cat Beijing is long hair yeah and there
she gets hair yeah so I'm glad she
doesn't roll around in her clothes
because baby balls every two or three
days yeah you know because she's shorter
but yeah alright so let's take a break
and then when we come back we will talk
more okay everybody Ginny's got some new
shirt designs up four of them really
good ones to Atlanta Ripper who put
Bella in the which out the HH Holmes
murder castle and of course demon child
cuz man said he could these are updated
designs I think they look really cool
Jenny did a great job autumn where they
found making Jenny they were very fun
and thank you very much I think they
came out really good they're very
high-quality shirts Jenny and I we're
sure our own shirts at certain times
when we're trying to put spotlight on
ourselves and you can put a spotlight on
yourselves if you go ahead and pick up
on these shirts today you guys are gonna
love them links in the description
WWL comm at 13 o'clock yes ago check out
our store at wwl com / 13 o'clock we got
these four cool new t-shirt designs plus
all our old ones if you'd rather get one
of the old ones but these ones are
awesome and you should check them out
they're also available in women's cut
they look really cute JD's got some so
thank you go check them out
you what you do
Hey what the hell was that you doing
yeah okay
the faceless villain a collection of the
eeriest unsolved murders of the 20th
century volume 2 includes cases spanning
the years from 1960 through 1979
featuring such infamous crimes as the
triple homicide at Lake Bodom the family
massacre known as the good heart murders
the serial killings of the Zodiac Bible
John Jack the stripper and the freeway
phantom the slaughter of dozens of women
and girls along the highway of tears and
the Texas killing fields and the
mysterious death of suspected spy the is
doll woman along with dozens of other
fascinating and horrifying accounts by
it now from Amazon in print Kindle or
audiobook format alright we are back
talking about the Son of Sam killings I
think we got the camera back to where it
was 45 minutes I thought this would take
an hour but again I was wrong this is
wrong well and the thing is because I'm
always wrong okay you don't know how
long and how long it takes to do [ __ ]
and plus I think a lot of the problem
too is that you start drinking and then
start talking and then you go on and on
and on I'm going on and on no not right
now alright alright so the next you know
I'm trying to keep [ __ ] somewhat on
track you know you know how that goes
but like I said it seems like that's why
even though sometimes I'm looking at my
notes going banging on all cylinders and
start taking the show down a creative
path yeah we might be recording another
we're gonna be yeah when they're making
comments that usually talking about the
crazy [ __ ] that I did on the side I have
noticed that like always like commenting
about like the extra [ __ ] like the
videos like yeah yeah we said because
this is most people are tuning in
because of entertainment yeah you know
the case is part of it get these dry ass
cases anywhere yeah we're giving it the
this dry ass case in a damn informative
and entertaining me so alright so
actually the next crime that occurred
was actually his only solo victim this
was Virginia and I hope I'm pronouncing
this right Bhaskar rich Ian or vasca
Ricci in she was a student at Columbia
University she was only 19 years old on
March 8 1977 is about 7:30 in the
evening so point early she was actually
walking home from class when this
[ __ ] just like walked up to her
and this detail breaks my [ __ ] heart
she was carrying her textbooks right he
pulls out the gun and points it at her
and she very quickly quick thinking I
wouldn't have thought of this she pulled
her textbooks up in front of her face
like to try to lock the book lock the
bullet it didn't work went through it
anyway and got her yeah so she died
anyway now interestingly like I said and
here is some more evidence why people
think that this was more than one
shooter because someone who lived in the
area they heard the gunshots they were
coming around the corner onto the same
street and this actually occurred only a
couple of blocks from where Christine
Freund got shot so he's kind of going
back to you know the same kind of
hunting grounds at the same
neighborhoods so in this neighborhood
this resident is like walking across
like comes around a corner like right
near the crime scene and he almost runs
into a person that he said was like a
teenager he said he was like 16 18 years
old he said he was kind of chubby
clean-shaven he said he was wearing a
sweater and like a cap and that he was
like running away from the crime scene
and that when he saw this kid the kid
like pulled his hat down over his face
and said something like oh Jesus or
something like that
so other people said that they had seen
this person also like kind of hanging
around the neighborhood and I thought he
looks kind of suspicious people in the
neighborhood also described somebody who
looked like David Berkowitz hanging
around the neighborhood as well so there
was that whole issue going on too so at
this stage I'm not sure like I don't
think the cops considered the chubby
teenager person I don't know if they
considered him a suspect or just a
witness or something like that at this
stage they're kind of feeling like
because of the you know 44 caliber
bullets that were using all the
similarity in MO they've kind of come to
the conclusion that all of these were
probably committed by the same person
now at this stage they're like the dark
haired person that was described in like
in one of the earlier shootings is
probably the suspect most of the other
people that you know various witnesses
had seen were being sought as witnesses
not necessarily as suspects this was
probably this was right around the time
to when the media started to like really
go crazy with this [ __ ] and it was just
like I mean it wasn't just like the New
York me it was everywhere all over the
country was all over the world really I
mean it was like this big huge deal like
some random [ __ ] going around
just like shooting people in New York
City yeah this is not normal no I mean
New York City at the time you know the
the crime rate was very high you know
there was a lot of muggings a lot of
rapes a lot it was all understandable
stuff happening in places where yeah
okay most of it most crime is very
what's good pedestrian you know
robberies you know and I mean robbing
stores but stuff like this actually it
stands out in the United States yeah
well in kind of nicer neighborhoods too
right like it wasn't like some you know
crack den or no that were no one would
think twice about it a lot of the
average crime the United States also is
like bad guy on bad guy too usually over
the drug trade yeah that's me most of it
you never hear about it and honestly
crime is gone
I mean not just the United States but in
Canada has precipitously drop yeah since
the 1990s yeah there are no one is quite
sure exactly why it's probably like a
can whole confluence of factors yeah um
like you said some people said it's like
LEDs I think it was like more than the
environment that is one factor that a
lot of people have mentioned ours back
in those days ran leaded gasoline yeah
and those cars blue LED particles
everywhere every city we just was you
know have a bunch of lead in it that
lowers your IQ it makes you violent so
that is one thing you know
yeah and old timers that I know that you
know from the proper backgrounds law
enforcement type background said really
the worst was the 70s well I think in
terms of actual body count it might have
been the 80s and because there probably
thrown in the crack epidemic yeah you
know I mean which that was you know I
think it spiked in 89 and then started
going draft yeah the whole crack war was
pretty bad but evidently just in terms
of just pure ruthlessness the 70s was
supposed to be the worst that's what I'm
like I was just a kid then but yeah it
really did seem what I think about was
and when you think about it that was the
height of leaded gasoline yeah and like
I said you're not the first person to
say that because that is one of the
factors that people people also point to
you know abortion had been made legal
too so maybe some people that would have
been born criminals weren't born you
know what I mean so that they said that
might have kind of helped out baby yeah
but there was a bunch of you know a
bunch of you know started calling out
the yeah right exactly which you know
that might have been a factor calling
out the unwanted kids yeah but I do
think led might have been a I think it
was lead poisoning
thank you because the Romans had a
similar problem yeah with lead piping
for their water yes is your brain up and
the Romans yeah they speak honestly
ancient Romans showed some weird
behaviors especially in the royal class
yeah why because they could afford lead
plates and they ate awful ed utensils
yeah they thought lead made food taste
better because when you're cutting on
their little lead particles getting the
the poisoning makes I like it salt yeah
yeah so it all starts to make sense to
me they were violent people yeah you
know I think it was leaded gasoline yeah
because I mean you have to think like
since the 70s like jewish-led has been
taken out of the environment out of the
water right here there was some kind of
a big difference some people that are
into this theory say that in the inner
cities decades of lead particles from
the traffic built up in those cities and
they blew her out blue round in the wind
yes but it stayed there for a long long
time
I liked your blowing around yeah it's my
blowing around yeah yes she she talks
[ __ ] about drinking yeah she's over
there pounded pounding vodka I wasn't
talking [ __ ] I like tradition it was
entertaining all right partially I think
you might be honest I think that I'd
like I said I think it was a lot of
factors but I think that was probably
one of the factors yeah so all right
here we go
so like I said newspapers start to
report this [ __ ] it's always like in
headlines all over the [ __ ] world
now the next shooting took place on
April 17th 1977 now this was back in the
Bronx most of the earlier ones like I
said the first one was in the Bronx and
then it was like Queens Queens Queens
and then this one's back in the Bronx
again and this was actually only a
couple blocks from the Lauria Valenti
Valenti shooting now this was Alexander
Esau who was 20 and Valentina suriani
who was 18 again they were sitting in a
car near her house and somebody just
came up and started shooting each of
them were shot twice
valentina actually died at the scene and
Alexander died later on in the hospital
neither of them got a look at their
attacker so you know they couldn't
describe him so they you know this is
the same weapon so again police are like
okay well this is the 44 caliber killer
cuz that's what they were calling him at
this point he wasn't called the Son of
Sam yet until now because at this crime
scene
they found a letter written and like
kind of block letters and I just saw
what I was researching this somebody
made a font I can't read what it's
called I think it's called Son of Sam
but it was made a font out of the
writing from the Son of Sam letters
because he had like a very particular
way of like writing block letters so
somebody made a fonts out of that so
yeah I don't know but yeah so this is
the first time that he referred to
himself as Son of Sam as I said before
he'd been called the 44 caliber killer
now this letter I'm not gonna read the
whole thing they didn't publish the
whole thing at first because like I said
the cops like to like hold details back
just in case somebody comes in and
confesses or whatever so they didn't
publish all of it but they did publish
like bits of it in the papers and in
this one is like it's really badly
spelled again this easy him in the
zodiac it's like maybe they don't know
how to spell it's like you know what I
mean
that's one of the things I'm deeply hurt
by you're calling me a women hater
it's like whamon but he o say so he says
he's not a woman hater but he does say
he's a monster this is and he says I'm
Son of Sam
he says I'm a little brat he says he
starts saying all this stuff about
father Sam like he commands me to kill
blah-dee-blah and he's killed all these
people and they're just like bones
buried underneath you know he's like I'm
a different wavelength and everyone else
I'm programmed to kill he tells the
police if you see me shoot to kill or
else keep out of my way bla bla bla then
he says something about papa Sam is old
now he needs some blood to preserve his
youth he has had too many heart attacks
and he repeats that two times too many
heart attacks
um and then he says something about I
missed my pretty princess not really
sure who he's referring to there and
then he calls himself monster Beelzebub
and my very favorite the chubby behemoth
which okay yeah Joby alright yeah so he
said the we bond
of Queens RZ prettiest of all and I'm
not even gonna show you how that spelled
I don't want to kill any more no sir but
I must to the people of Queens I love
you I'm gonna wish you all a happy
Easter may God bless you yada yada okay
because yours and murder mr. monster
that's how we send it do you think that
he's trolling this huh yeah Thank You
sterling I mean it sounds like sound to
me it sounds like he's trying to throw
them off yeah it sounds like a crazy
person wrote it but it could also be
somebody trying to sound like a crazy
yeah I think so I think it doesn't sound
doesn't sound authentic to me I mean I
know that he wrote it yeah but it sounds
like he's trying to throw the law
enforcement off off of his trail yeah it
doesn't sound like that and it's not
even really a good attempt it's like a
lame attempt yeah they're trying to
throw him off yeah it's like most of the
[ __ ] it's like what the [ __ ] yeah but
well the interesting thing too is that
when he kept saying stuff about Papa Sam
and likey he's had too many heart
attacks um they have noted that a couple
of the victims were nurses or like
nursing students so they're like maybe
there was some kind of thing there like
maybe he had a father figure that had a
heart attack of like someone didn't save
him or whatever they're overthinking it
that's what I mean so I don't know it's
just like that's kind of thing so after
this letter was received the police
consulted a whole bunch of different
psychiatrist and were like what do you
think of this and then they developed
like a psychological profile of who they
thought the killer was um they thought
that he probably suffered from various
neuroses obviously perhaps paranoid
schizophrenia and they also thought that
he probably believed that he was
demonically possessed because it did
kind of sound like that from the letter
yeah and I think that's what he wanted
them to think yeah and he has I mean as
far as I know still to this day he still
contends that he was in a satanic cult
back then and that he was not there but
he hasn't denied murdering some of those
people he said he did but he said he
wasn't the only one that I don't think
he's trying to get some of the
top of him and say well I was in this
organization was making me do this yeah
because he kind of went here's the thing
when he was in prison he went all
born-again Christian there's a lot of
them do and I feel like you know and he
writes for a lot of Christian websites
and like you know he's trying to get
forgiveness and blah blah blah so I do
kind of feel like he's maybe trying to
expiate some of the guilt yes maybe so
so there was that letter and then
another letter shows up on May 30th 1977
and this was addressed to a guy named
Jimmy Breslin he was a common columnist
at The Daily News and it's funny because
this letter was a lot it's still crazy
but it was a lot better written like a
lot better spell for sure but it kind of
looked like it was from the same person
now it had been postmarked from
Englewood New Jersey so I'm not sure how
significant that is but it said the same
kind of stuff that you know all this
[ __ ] about Sam and like you know I'm
Sam's creation and all this other kind
of stuff now again at the end of this
letter he's talking about other people
to look into and this is something that
he was pointing back to when he was
talking about it was a satanic cult blah
blah blah um he said that there was
somebody called the Duke of Death
he said there was somebody called the
wicked King wicker the 22 disciples of
Hell John Wheaties who he called a
rapist and suffocate or of young girls
and so he's saying that all these people
are like related to the crime and this
was back then this was 1977 so
underneath and he actually signed this
one set of Sam and then there was like
this weird like logo type of thing
underneath now in this particular letter
he had said something to the effect of
what will you have for July 29th which
the police took as a threat that
something was going to happen on that
day so you know so that Breslin like
contact the police and said hey I think
something Bad's gonna happen now at this
stage because of the way the letter was
laid out and the way it was written and
the logo that was drawn at the bottom it
seemed very professional looking they
thought that maybe
somebody that was familiar with graphic
design or you know or was a comic letter
or perhaps or knew about printing or
something like that because it was like
a good looking letter I guess but as I
said it's it was a lot better spelled
than the first one even though it was
just like as crazy as the other one
so then there was another shooting June
26 1977
this was Sal Lupo who was 20 and Judy
Placido who was 17 this was also in
Queens they had left a disco they were
sitting in a parked car and it was 3
a.m. and somebody came up and shot into
the vehicle three times Sal was actually
shot in the arm Judy was shot in the
head shoulder and back of the neck but
they both survived they told the police
later they said it's funny well not
funny but you know funny weird not funny
ha ha that they were like sitting in the
car and they'd actually been talking
about the Son of Sam case right before
the Son of Sam came up and shot them so
you know just saying it was that's super
creepy so neither one of them saw him
but two other people in the area said
they had seen a dark haired man who was
tall and he was wearing a leisure suit
seventies y'all and that he was running
away from the area now one of these
people said they saw him get in a car
and drive away and this person actually
had the presence of mind to write down
part of the license plate yeah yeah yeah
so now interestingly another witness in
the same area again described a blond
man with a mustache who drove off in a
Chevy Nova that didn't have its
headlights on yeah so again like I said
not crazy that they think maybe there
was more than one but they at this stage
they're thinking okay well the dark
haired man this dark haired suspect that
has been seen at most of these crime
scenes he's probably the shooter maybe
these other people are just witnesses or
happened to be in the area now if I
remember correctly correct me if I'm
wrong this license plate that was
written down leads to a license plate
that eventually gets a tip
parking this was late this happened
later yeah okay so but this license
plate that was written down it is
Berkowitz license plate I'm actually not
sure if this is the same one or not okay
all right because I was just I'm going
through the timeline right because I was
just thinking that I know how he was
eventually caught yeah I don't wanna
spoil it for these people that really
don't know but it had to do with license
plates and tickets Thank You Justin hey
man cool like I said Khan make some make
some [ __ ] just you should so
then at this stage there the police are
freaking out because you know it's been
a year since the first 44 caliber killer
murders and they're afraid that there's
gonna be like some big thing on that day
so there's like this huge dragnet
they're like you know have [ __ ] cops
everywhere and all this other stuff you
know in Queens and the Bronx and
everywhere however because the cops were
out in force in Queens in the Bronx the
next shooting happened in Brooklyn so he
went somewhere else right July 31st 1977
this was Stacey Moskowitz and Robert
Violante they're both 20 years old they
were sitting in Robert volantes car and
it was parks like you know on the side
of the street like in a area and a
neighborhood called bath Beach which
actually a nice you know kind of upper
middle class neighborhood
sitting in the car making out like you
do some man comes to around to the
passenger side and fires four rounds
into the car shooting both victims in
the head
Stacey actually died in the hospital
Robert Violante actually lived but lost
all of the sight in one eye and most of
the sight in his other eye to shame now
this particular crime this one had a lot
of witnesses there was this guy named
Tommy Zane oh he was 19 and he was in a
car you know with his date with his
girlfriend like only three cars in front
of you know the car where the shooting
had happened and he actually looked in
his rearview mirror and saw
so he got a pretty good look at the
person that was shooting into the car
because it was apparently was under
street light it was a full moon bla bla
bla he described him as being late 20s
or 30 years old five foot seven and five
foot nine shaggy hair that was dark
blond or light brown although he said
the hair looked like a wig and
interestingly another couple that were
in the area at the time specifically
also said that they saw a white male
wearing a light-colored cheap nylon wig
so this very well could have been
Berkowitz disguising himself but not in
a very not a really good way because
even from far away people are like yeah
looks like a wig yeah he's a wig and
they all said they saw the card it was
like a light-colored compact car like
driving away from the scene without
headlights on now this at this stage one
of the women who was also parked
alongside she wrote down part of the
license when she got most of it she said
I wasn't sure like what the first couple
letters and numbers were but she's like
I know that for you know the last ones
were either for GU ra4 GVR so that so
she wrote it down so at this stage a
bunch of witnesses have reported seeing
what they described as a yellow
Volkswagen or a yellow compact car like
driving away from the scene sometimes
without headlights on some people have
described someone who looks very much
like David Berkowitz would end up
looking some people described a white
man in his late 20s who looked like a
grubby hippie or had like a skinny face
or something like that so you know there
was all kind of at this stage they were
kind of like there were differing
witness accounts but most of them were
more similar than they had been in the
past now there's this guy who was named
Thomas Scalia I'm not sure if that's his
real name or if it's a pseudonym because
I know that though some of the witnesses
they give them pseudonyms but he said
that he was sitting in a park and you
know with a friend of his who was a girl
and that someone like a yellow
Volkswagen be able to like pulled up
alongside
and he like got scared and he had like
an air pistol or something like that
like under his seat of his car so he
like pulled it out and pointed it the
guy and the guy took off so they think
maybe that was him too now this person
reported that it was a light-skinned
black man but he also said that it
looked like he had a stocking over his
face so that might have been right that
was so like I said a lot of people say
in a yellow Volkswagen which is spoiler
alert not the car that it ended up being
although it was yellow so at this point
they actually weren't sure they didn't
know until a little bit later that it
this was actually like another son of
Sam killing um this actually ended up
being the last one because shortly after
this there was a woman named Cecilia
Davis and she had been walking her dog
in the neighborhood where the shooting
occurred now she saw someone walking
down the street acting suspiciously who
looked kind of like David Berkowitz and
she said that he looked at me like
interestedly like hey I could shoot that
person you know I'm just you know
speculating but um I'm assuming that
that's what she meant and then she heard
gunshots so she ran back to her house
and she said that she had seen a cop
putting a ticket on this particular car
because it was parked by a fire hydrant
so since the cops were thinking well
this car was actually in this area at
the night of night of the shooting so
they pulled all the tickets that they
had given in that area that night and
there weren't that many one of them
belonged to a 1970 Ford or a yellow Ford
Galaxie belonging to one David Berkowitz
yeah so finally they actually they're
going to interview them so they said
they go to pick him up now they look in
the car you know that had got the ticket
that they knew belonged to him and they
see like a shotgun or a rifle now these
were technically legal but they kind of
used that an excuse to like search the
car and they wanted to search the
apartment and stuff like that they also
found like so when they searched the car
they found it for like a bunch of other
suspicious [ __ ] like some duffel bags
with a me
in there they felt like some maps of
crime scenes and also they found a
letter so yeah a shotgun also in there's
a shotgun or a rifle yeah I think yeah I
think it was right yeah yeah okay so it
was so it was in the car and like I said
it was weird he had that in a car but
you could see it from the see it from
the way yeah you can see it just looking
at the window so obviously he wasn't all
that good well they weren't illegal like
you said but you would think that you
you know would try to hide that just
just so people wouldn't be curious yeah
but I don't think that dudes thinking is
too good but like I said they wanted to
you know they were kind of like staking
out the apartment they wanted to like
wait so if they'd want a big
confrontation and [ __ ] like that
but evidently so he gets out he comes
out of the apartment they he gets in his
car and then the cops like kind of
surround him um some sources say that
the first thing he said was oh you
finally got me what took you so long
some of the the guy that was the
arresting officer detective fellow tico
said now that I've got you who have I
got and apparently the suspect said you
know mm-hmm you know what I mean and
says so then the cop says no I don't
know like who are you and then he said
I'm Sam hmm
so that's how they was like so like I
said there's two different versions of
that story floating around but you know
pretty much the same thing so they go in
his apartment they find a bunch of like
satanic graffiti so we didn't pull that
entirely out of his ass
you know they did find all that [ __ ] on
those apartment walls he had actually
kept a bunch of journals and [ __ ] since
he was 21 years old and he had like a
bunch of notebooks that he had written
and and there was all kind of that was
when they first found out about the
arsons because he talked about all of
him in there they're like oh we were
wondering you did as it was this yeah so
they think it was like like I said 1400
1500 arsons that's a lot of arsons right
yeah so at this stage the cops are
pretty sure they're like okay this has
got to be Son of Sam so they did a press
conference and they're like okay we
caught him it's fine now they he
actually confessed pretty much right
away like
like the morning that they captured him
he said I'm gonna plead guilty and at
this stage it was where he very famously
said that he started killing people
because the neighbor's dog told him to
do told him to do it like I don't know
if he it was the kind of thing where
either the dog the dog's name was Harvey
he was a black Labrador either the dog
was possessed by a demon or the dog was
possessed by the neighbor whose name was
Sam who was the devil and he was like
speaking through the dog and like
telling him to kill people so that was
like the first thing this is like the
dog said that he needed like the blood
of pretty girls for whatever reason he
wasn't taking the Bloods he's [ __ ]
yeah he was just shooting people yeah so
yeah Sam Carr was his neighbor and that
was his dog and he said that the dog was
telling him to do that now even though
he was saying there was another thing to
that he said like during his confession
that made other people think that you
know maybe there were more than one he
said there are other sons out there like
other sons of Sam so some people took
that to mean that you know yes so
despite how crazy all this [ __ ] sounded
yes like a dog told me to shoot people
he was assessed by several different
mental health professionals and they all
said he is competent to stand trial you
know what I mean he is not he knows
right from wrong clearly yes yeah he's
fantasizing and trying to get people to
buy into this fantasy come on now his
lawyer actually asked him they said hey
you might want to say not guilty by
reason of insanity but David Berkowitz
said no that he wasn't gonna do that
went insane you just in league with the
devil
yeah so he actually pleaded guilty at
his trial so they didn't have to go
through a big room to do or anything
like that he just said yep I did it
whatever um he was actually very calm at
the initial like little trial or hearing
or whatever however two weeks later when
they were doing the sentencing he very
famously tried to jump out of a seventh
floor window damn unfortunately he did
not succeed but yeah so they they
restrained him and he started chanting
wasn't unfortunate though
he was trying to take the easy way out
true make that [ __ ] stay in
prison yeah he still is yeah like I said
he said oh yeah now after they
restrained him after this little stunt
he started chanting Stacy is a [ __ ]
Stacy Stacy was one of his victims
yes so you know so there was a whole
thing like I even have I found a court
drawing because you know how to have the
people like Jarrah that do the court
drawings and the courtroom drawings and
stuff and I'm like oh like they had to
restrain him Lee just trying to check
out isn't it so now it was only after
all of this [ __ ] about what the dogs
possessed by a demon and he told me
about blah and I'm in a satanic cult
null another [ __ ]
it should be noted that in 1979 yeah he
called all that demonic possession stuff
quote-unquote a hoax Yeah right so he
even told that to the court-appointed
psychiatrist in fact off of that yeah
and he I mean he basically said now he's
kind of gone back to it in years but in
1979 this is only two years after he got
caught yeah um he said yeah that whole
dog thing and the demon thing I've seen
it that's a hoax they made that up and
he actually even said the dog thing was
made up by the media no the police said
no that's what he said but whatever but
then he said in 1979 he's like no I was
just murdering people because people
rejected me and you know so I was just
getting back at them or whatever so they
first sent him to like a psychiatric
ward and then they sent him around to
various prisons as I said in prison in
1987 he became a born-again Christian
and said that he would no longer like to
be referred to as the Son of Sam he now
wants to be referred to as the son of
hope no and yeah I was like well yeah so
he apparently he writes for a lot of
like I didn't go read anything but he
apparently writes for a lot of Christian
websites and he's like asking for
forgiveness and actually some of the
victims families have forgiven him which
fair plain to them that's more than I do
sorry man
I wouldn't be able to do that I just
can't so you know there was that whole
thing and like I said they have um even
though he got six consecutive life
sentences he does come up for parole
every now and then I think it's the law
you supposed to come up for a parole
hearing Lee
over two years depending on what your
sentence was but he has consistently
like refused no and there I don't think
they would let him out anyways the
[ __ ] son of Sam even though he says he
got like all kind of honorary degrees in
prison and all this other kind of
shayzon man but yeah but he's he's been
a model prisoner blah blah blah but I've
noticed and like I said there was even
one of those like [ __ ] 80 like
criminal shows with what's under his
name bill [ __ ] I can't last name right
now I'm too drunk but but there was a
whole thing like where he was
interviewed and it looked like probably
80s or yeah you know maybe 90s cuz he
still looked pretty young where he's
just going on about this satanic cult
thing and some of the people that he
referred to like in that letter that he
sent to Jimmy Breslin they do refer to
actual people so and like I said some
people have pointed to this whole well
some of the witnesses all blonde guys
I'm such I'm a teenager some such of our
vehicles blah blah so maybe there was
more than one person know like working
at this so he's really been kind of
working that angle where yeah I was
recruited into a satanic cult by Sam
Carr who was you know who owned the dog
that was supposedly telling him to kill
people and the son now by the time he
said this though Sam car and the other
guy that were suppose they were both
dead yeah think about how unlikely that
would be see yeah there was a big
satanic cult and only one of them got
caught yeah where are the other ones
they were doing that [ __ ] to they get
caught now oh yeah and some of them were
dead before he started saying that yeah
so I'm not saying it's not possible
anything's possible
no after they died he started to say
that because mine wouldn't be you know I
don't buy the whole I was in a satanic
cult and they were there too and
honestly like there have been some
investigators that thought yeah maybe
it's maybe he did have an accomplice or
two accomplices or whatever
not necessarily the satanic cult thing
now they actually did reopen the
investigation in 1996 because they
thought the not necessarily satanic cult
but the fact that he might have had
accomplices they thought that was worth
exploring the case is still technically
open but it's
kind of like inactive because they
didn't really find any evidence to
pursue like any new lead if he had an
accomplice who did the accomplice kill
see that's what's now he said that he
only killed three of the people he only
did three of the shootings so he didn't
like deny doing the shooting they just
traded the pistol but he said he was
there at all of them but that he only
actually was the gunman on three of the
shooting it's unlikely now like I said
he was originally it was six murders and
seven attempted murders because seven
people a shot they lived
I say it's unlikely I think it's
unlikely yeah because a guy would
normally once he's coming up and coming
up a trolleybus yeah but I didn't kill
those I only killed the three yeah man
cuz he's gonna try the barter down for a
lighter system for a lighter sentence by
turning state's evidence against another
guy no although in some ways it's like
he's so [ __ ] old now it's like you
think that he would just stop it they
they're not waking about egos I guess
and you don't want to back up on the on
the lies that you've been telling you
know yeah I guess maybe he's just like
sunk himself in said he or maybe he's
like convinced himself of it after all
this time I mean all he's had he's just
been sitting there in prison and maybe
he like how maybe he's telling other
inmates this yeah in order to keep
himself alive or to keep himself from
being bothered you know yeah I was in a
satanic cult oh yeah bro cool yeah yeah
whatever
to make himself seem long yeah he's
living in prison Society so it's
different yeah yeah I mean it could be
yeah now some people have said that you
know even in some of his earlier like
confessions like back in 1979 and stuff
like that he had made reference to the
very famous murder of arles Perry
she was actually murdered in a church in
North Dakota and it's like I was reading
about her partner today it was unsolved
for a long time but they actually solved
it this year with DNA evidence the guy
that did it is dead he was like a
security guard at the church okay but
she she was murdered they found like a
[ __ ] they found her in the church and
she had like a candle like sticking out
of her
this is horrifying yeah it was like like
I said it was a very famous unsolved
case they finally solved it this year
but I think the person I don't think
that David Berkowitz like said that he
knew who did he was just implying he
implied that somebody that was in the
same cult like did that
yeah he's [ __ ] but like I said they
found out that it was it was like at the
time they didn't think it was because
his prints didn't match but when they
did a DNA test later on the guy was dead
by the time I got the wrong prints maybe
that's it or maybe it's just the prints
for somebody else for you so that's so
that's the thing like I said I'm not
sure how seriously I want to take they
like I said they did reopen the case in
1996 because they did feel like it was
looking and worth looking into that
maybe there were other people involved
but they didn't really find anything
definitive so and some investigators on
the case have said look you know we've
talked to David Berkowitz he has like a
pretty much photographic memory of all
of the crimes like he knows exactly
where everyone was like what exactly
happened it's like this is him and there
was no one no other person I'll tell you
this much though whoever the Zodiac
killer was it's gonna be a guy very
similar to David Berkowitz if you ask me
it seemed well it's a very similar modus
operandi he does pretty much the exact
same [ __ ] gonna be the same motive the
same khana guy I mean even like a lot of
the letters seem the same like the oh
I'm so crazy type though with the block
letters and all that kind of [ __ ] like I
said approaching random people in cars
and I would think probably military yeah
yeah for zodiac yeah probably military
somebody did see him and survived and
said that he did have kind of a military
bearing about himself yeah that is hair
the way way he was close it's weird it
does seem to be a lot of that I mean
like I said David Berkowitz was in the
Army yeah [ __ ] what's-his-face for
like gold in the state killer yeah he
was in the military
Oh some of them were yeah especially
especially like these times day killers
police
so military and police yeah yeah yeah I
do feel like well remember and I think I
mentioned this maybe on the Golden State
Killer captured show about how that was
one of the most common jobs serial
killers would be a copper this should be
ex-army and or cop yeah or weirdly like
forestry workers yeah although I tend to
think that the zodiac is ex-navy yeah or
marine yeah yes a lot of the little
glyphs that he used kind of had maritime
yeah and some of the things about the
way he with his shoes in his hair sounds
kind of like Navy yeah I feel like well
could Son of Sam like he didn't write as
many let cuz the Zodiac [ __ ] world
letters like all the time like at least
the ones that they know we're him
because there were some fakes later on
but you know he definitely had a thing
where he was just like even up after he
stopped killing people for years and
years afterward he would like keep
sending [ __ ] letters to the newspaper
now David Berkowitz didn't send that
many but it did seem like he was trying
to establish for lack of a better word a
brand yeah you know what I mean like Son
of Sam and then he would draw this
little logo and it was kind of like a
man symbol and a woman symbol and like
some other [ __ ] like yeah on there like
he was trying to do a logo like zodiac
I'm gonna say a Zodiac was Navy yeah and
the reason why I'm saying that is
because of a woman who survives seeing
him said that he had spit polish spit
shine shoes yeah that's not really a
hardcore army thing yeah
army infantry guys will blacken their
shoes they'll polish them a little bit
with some Kiwi but they won't go into
all that spit shine [ __ ] right that's
ramps rear echelon [ __ ] you
know I mean but when I was in the army
it was a kind of a thing I honor to have
kind of kind of worn out and kind of
torn up equipment yeah you you were but
you had a hard ride yeah you weren't one
of these guys that worked in an office
or worked on a ship or something like
that so the whole spit-shine thing that
sounds like Navy yeah yeah maybe I
should mention about the Son of Sam case
is that in the whole legal
Arina it's actually very famous because
when david berkowitz was caught he was
actually offered like large sums of
money by various newspapers book
publishers stuff like that for his story
so New York passed a law that you were
not allowed like serial killers or
murderers were not allowed to
financially benefit from stories told
about them and their families were not
because they didn't want to like
encourage you know somebody like hey I'm
gonna go and kill then it'll take care
of my family forever because I'll just
sell my story to the National Enquirer
so they are allowed to tell their
stories but they cannot get any
financial compensation for them and
neither can their families um this law
has actually been challenged on free
speech grounds but they were actually
able to pass it I think it's the law in
41 states I'm not sure like I think each
state has like different parameters I've
been stuff but generally if you're a
serial than a prison serial killer you
are not allowed to financially benefit
from telling your story to like these
paper books they're not allowed to pay
you they can give it to charity or
whatever but they can't give it to you
or your direct kin so and they call
those the Son of Sam laws that's why it
took that's why that took place because
there was so much money floating around
like people wanting Son of Sam to tell
and their story so that's how that went
all right so I think we've gone on way
way yeah well honestly it's like I'm
gonna edit it out but I had to stop
whole much times cuz I kept losing my
place in the notes like you said it's I
you know I do so much research than
others right I lose my place while I'm
trying to and plus I'm drinkin so and
I'm like what the [ __ ] I can this is a
seventy style Merv Griffin is with us
and everything the elevator can you guys
all know
yeah no no not not on this Friday it'll
be like a father Friday after that yeah
don't worry about it don't worry about
just shut it down
okay all right so we're gonna wrap up
the show about the Son of Sam hope you
enjoyed it and if if you like the show
to like share subscribe on all your
social media if you'd like to
financially support show you go to our
page
Paige patreon.com/scishow and more perks
like on the patreon page that's I'm
really trying to do that's one of my
resolutions also if you don't like
patreon it would rather give a one-time
donation that would also be greatly
appreciated you go to our blog which is
13 o'clock podcast WordPress comm and
there's a link in the sidebar to a
PayPal account
remember our movie retrospectives which
are usually old movies those come out
every Friday we also have 13 o'clock
matinee which comes out every two or no
Sunday those are like new movies in the
theatre and these episodes right here
come out every Tuesday so check them out
if you haven't already and we will wrap
it up now episode 126 we will see you
next time
you